it has been quite some time since nvidia
has graced us with a new 80 series gpu
20 months in fact since the last one so
we got the gtx 1080 in hands it felt
like a momentous occasion especially
with the vive and the oculus rift so
recently hitting market
and since nvidia is building their new
1080s pascal architecture as one of
their most ambitious projects yet and
saying that it can beat out their
flagship titan x and a pair of 980s in
sli i think it's time to see if it can
live up to the hype
[Music]
so the gtx 1080 is their first card in
their new line of pascal gpus continuing
the tradition of nvidia naming new
generations of gpus after old dead guys
who were legendarily good at physics and
math and speaking of math the cards
gp104 gpu can certainly do a lot of
processing with 2560 cuda cores
1733 megahertz base clock and a 16
nanometer process which is able to allow
them to pack way more transistors onto
the chip for increased performance
nvidia also switched to a new type of
vram called gddr5x which runs at about
10 gigabits per second nvidia says that
gddr5x combined with various
improvements like memory compression it
ends up being 1.7 times faster in terms
of effective memory bandwidth than a gtx
980. they crammed eight gigabytes of
this stuff inside the 1080 but if you
are more inclined to go for the 1070
when that comes out it also has 8
gigabytes but just more standard gddr5
so keep that in mind if you will be
disappointed by buying a product that
has slightly less x's on its product
sheet
but beyond raw specs there were also
some other features that nvidia baked
into the pascal pie such as simultaneous
multi-projection which allows pascal to
project 16 different viewports each with
the ability to rotate in order to better
match the current display setup that you
have and it has the ability to project
more than one of these viewports at once
this enables graphics techniques such as
perspective surround which can correct
image perspectives across multiple
monitors so you don't get that weird
warping on multi-monitor surround
anymore and like massive scale issues
and stuff that should be fixed then
there's a personal favorite of mine
single pass stereo this allows pascal to
render geometry for an object in vr only
once instead of twice per eye then it
just uses simple transforms to generate
the view for both eyes
but if you're not really into vr and you
want something for the desktop side
never fear there's something for you as
well and that's called multi-res shading
nvidia included multi-res shading for
the desktop guys as well it allows you
to focus more of your gpu power near the
center of the screen and less on the
outside this will result in higher
resolution and detail in the middle and
lower resolution and detail on the
outside where you are theoretically
paying less attention to this should
help performance but we'll see if it
really matters later on
when used for vr various smp techniques
including the ones not fully covered
here equate to 1.5 times the pixel
throughput and two times the geometry
throughput than would otherwise have
been possible then there's ansel
technology which was introduced to take
gaming screenshots to the next level
which sounds like the most boring thing
possible but just hang with me it allows
you to take screenshots from any angle
and position by using a free-floating
camera that can detach from your
character it also allows you to run
simple filters over these images for
that oh so professional instagram look
it also allows you to take raw or exr
photos giving you full dynamic range for
all your image editing needs it takes
said photos or screenshots in super
resolution which is currently limited to
4.5
gigapixel images with 3600 cuda stitched
tiles this limitation is because of game
settings the resolution of the game and
the speed of your storage drive so it
should actually be expected to increase
in the future and last but not least is
360 degree photos so you can capture
those legendary fight scenes in
awesomely unique ways and then view them
in vr or whatever although when all is
said and done i expect most of the
pictures from ansel will be using the
free camera to capture derpy faces of
npcs
ansel does have to be enabled by the
developer and right now there's only a
relatively short list of games that
support it and i wouldn't expect a huge
amount of multiplayer games to either
yes the division is included but i think
it's not going to be in the dark zone
that's it for ansel and then we come to
vr works audio and vr works touch vr
audio can trace the physical path of
sound to give you a more realistic
experience while you're using a headset
and vr touch uses phys x to improve on
how things in the environment react with
your virtual hands both of these should
make pretty good improvements in terms
of immersion in the future once they're
more implemented now we got our hands on
the founders edition which sounds fancy
but is really just what nvidia is
calling the reference version of this
card and is selling for 6.99 a full
more than the msrp for base models from
add-in partners whose cards i expect to
see at computex like they were last time
so stay tuned to linus tech tips for
that nvidia is trying to justify the
higher cost by saying that they're using
premium components in manufacturing like
die cast aluminum and a low profile
backplate along with a vapor chamber
which should improve cooling but it's
important to note that the chips in the
founder's edition boards shouldn't be
binned in any way the cooler for the
1080 is similar to the silver and black
shrouds and blower style fan that we've
seen nvidia doing for quite a while now
but has a more angled aggressive look
reminiscent of basically every
environment in the last deus ex game the
connectivity support is good as it
features hdmi 2.0 for 4k at 60 hertz
three displaypoint 1.4 connectors for 4k
at 120 hertz or 8k at 60 hertz holy crap
and a dual link dvi however the 1080
only supports two-way sli natively even
though it has two sli fingers that is
because the 2s live fingers have been
teamed together to improve bandwidth
with the new sli bridge nvidia no longer
recommends three and four-way sli which
is probably a good thing to be honest
but they do suggest if you need to burn
that much money on that many cards that
you do two-way sli and have a third card
just for phys x but it is possible to
force three-way and four-way sli if you
sign up for nvidia enthusiast key which
registers your card i expect an even
worse experience from this form of sli
than past versions of sli and would
wholeheartedly
not recommend it all in all nvidia has
called this the largest chip processor
endeavor in the history of humanity with
a multi-billion dollar budget which
nvidia's ceo speculated might be enough
to go to mars but as nvidia is in the
business of making gpus not sending
people off to other worlds for
interplanetary lan parties
let's move on and just a note if it
seems like we don't have a lot of amd
cards in our testing it's because the
new polaris amd architecture which is
supposed to compete with pascal is right
around the corner it's not quite here
yet we'll have much more from the red
team when those cards drop with that
being said let's have a look at how the
benchmarking turned out all the testing
was done at 4k because what's the point
of running things at lower res when you
have the power of something like a 1080
and speaking of which if you do have
this nice setup but a 1080p monitor it's
better to run your games at higher
resolutions anyways with super sampling
and then just have them displayed on
your 1080p monitor if you're wondering
how to do that check the guide up here
we are waiting for the vr games market
to mature a bit before we test it very
much because it's a little bit messy
right now but we did throw crisis 3 and
star wars battlefront at the 1080 and
various other cars to see how they would
perform and the 1080 solidly beat the
fury x and titan x and then ran right
alongside the sli 980s which was quite
impressive having a single card run toe
to toe with a dual card setup while
being just over half the price is a
strong start for our new funny-named
friend for directx 12 performance we
booted up rise of the tomb raider and
hitman the 1080 pulled off some
impressive numbers crushing the titan x
and laughing at the 980s as they flopped
around and confused sli enabled circles
as they struggled with poor dx12
optimizations amd's performance here was
stronger than the 900 series but the
1080 was still able to manage an overall
victory
while those numbers were a little bit
all over the directx 11 performance for
these games was more of a standard curve
with performance expectations lining up
nice and orderly if you're aiming for 4k
at 60fps then the 1080 will not
disappoint as it's able to run
everything on high presets near or above
60 frames per second proving the
respectively cheaper and when looking at
the titan x better performing option on
the nvidia side for power draw the
entire bench only drew 252 watts from
the wall which gives you a ton
of options in terms of lower wattage
power supplies or even sfx power
supplies and whatnot the thermals were
standard fare from nvidia with all of
our cards holding steady at around 81 to
83 degrees celsius
sorry nvidia's claims about it beating a
titan x and sli 980 is true i'd say
mostly it does cleanly beat the titan x
across the board but putting it up
against a 980 duo is a bit more of a
mixed bag it won some of the benchmarks
but lost others the loss is however at
least in actual games were quite narrow
and in any event the 1080 is clearly the
better choice for newer games especially
when they have dx12 support and it frees
you from the well documented issues with
sli
for dollars per frame we're assuming a
value of 599 for the 1080 in our
calculations as we expect whatever
you're able to get from the add-in board
partners should either match or beat the
reference founders edition card while
being a hundred dollars cheaper so this
dollars per frame is for pascal 1080 in
general not the founders edition
the 1080 blows everything away in this
metric except for the r9 390 x in hitman
specifically but when you consider that
the 390x has lower frame rates across
the board it's still a pretty darn
compelling value to get an aftermarket
1080. so what's our conclusion well for
599 dollars if that is your budget for a
card the 1080 is a no-brainer it's
ability to hit 60fps at 4k with lots of
eye candy in the latest titles combined
with per frame cost that's basically the
lowest in the world of high-end graphics
cards right now it's a pretty obvious
choice again if that is your budget we
still haven't gotten a single gpu card
that can run 4k games at 60fps with max
settings without breaking a sweat and at
600 the 1080 is still pretty steep in
terms of pricing but it is the king of
the hill for now it'll be interesting to
see what results we can get with
overclocking as nvidia is claiming a lot
in that department and how well amd's
polaris will answer this challenge
especially once directx 12 games hit the
market later this year thanks for
watching guys hopefully the animal noise
is
weren't too annoying this was filmed in
mexico we are not back yet um although
the embargo will be like
six hours after we land or something so
if you liked the video like it if you
disliked it and you were like this was
filmed in a ghetto way and there's
animal noises
you can dislike it be subscribed if you
want to see more coverage of the 1080 if
it's anything like 980 we'll release a
lot of videos on it uh if you want a
t-shirt that's cool you can check out
the link in the description down below
you can become a contributor on the
forum you can use our amazon affiliate
code to buy stuff like new gpus in the
next little while polaris
pascal which one you get which p are you
deciding to go for i don't know it's up
to you uh yeah
check out this video this is the launch
video for the gtx 980. i don't know why
you would watch it right now but go
watch it anyways and i'll see you next
time